-All right, here's how it works.
I'm going to press
this button here,
which activates
the impression generator.
It will land
on one random celebrity
who we can do an impression of
and one random topic.
And so whoever's turn it is,
they have to do an impression
of that celebrity
talking about that topic.
Since you're my guest,
my first guest, you go first.
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
Press the button,
and the game begins.
♪♪
Ooh, Jason Statham.
-Jason.
[ Laughter ]
-Talking about troll dolls.
-Okay.
-I didn't know
you did a Jason Statham.
-I don't know if I do.
Okay.
-All right.
-Okay.
-Jason talking about
troll dolls.
-All right.
[ Clears throat ]
[ British accent ]
"Here's the 'troof.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Nothing quite pisses me off
like those little troll dolls."
[ Laughter ]
"I just rip off
their [bleep] heads."
[ Laughter ]
"I can say [bleep]
because I'm from the U.K."
[ Laughter ]
"You can say that.
That's right, in the U.K.,
where I was
a competitive-level diver."
[ Laughter ]
"It's true.
I was a competitive diver.
Google it.
Or as we say in the U.K.,
Ask Jeeves."
[ Laughter ]
"Anyway..."
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Anyway, back to the dolls.
I still look better
than them naked, see?"
-Oh, my God.
That's insane.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness!
That is phenomenal!
-Thank you.
-That was phenomenal.
All right, here we go.
This is my turn.
Ask Jeeves...
-Ask Jeeves.
All right.
-Regis.
[ Laughter ]
Regis Philbin talking about
"Hot Girl Summer."
Okay.
All right.
"All right. Let me --
Let me tell you something.
[ Laughter ]
I am missing
"Hot Girl Summer" already.
It is fall.
I'm counting down the days when
I can sip rosé with my squad...
[ Laughter ]
...and play our favorite bops.
Like Lizzo."
-Yeah, sure.
-"For example,
I just took a DNA test."
-Oh, yeah?
-"And it turns out
I'm 100% that bitch!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
"100%!"
-100%.
-All right, Nick.
You're up.
-Okay, I'm gonna press
this real button.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Okay.
-Oh, Pitbull.
-Pitbull.
-It is real, yes.
Pitbull.
-Pitbull, flu shots.
-Talking about flu shots.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I don't know
if I know how Pitbull talks.
-Okay -- okay.
"Aha!"
[ Laughter ]
"Miami Beach, Mr. 305,
coming at you to say
you got to get
your flu shots, man!"
[ Laughter ]
Germs are going worldwide,
baby."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-"It won't hurt at all.
It just stings for a second."
That's one, two, three, four."
Uno, dos, tres, cuatro!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
Phenomenal!
All right,
we have time for one more,
and it is my turn.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Seinfeld, sure.
Surprise party.
Jerry Seinfeld
talking about surprise parties.
-Okay.
-"Okay, okay.
What's with all the secrecy?"
[ Laughter ]
"I come to an empty apartment,
which is exactly
what I wanted for my birthday.
But I turn the lights on,
and all of sudden, "Surprise!"
The only surprise is,
you have to make small talk
for four hours now."
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, get it together, Jerry!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"George!
George, what are you doing here,
George?"
-"That's right. I put this
party together, Jerry.
I put it together.
I schemed it together."
-"You shouldn't scheme.
No one should scheme."
-"Oh, I schemed, Jerry!"
[ Laughter ]
"George is getting upset!"
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a good George.
-It's a little bit --
It's a little...
-You helped me
with my impression!
That's all the time we have
for "Wheel of Impressions."